je vous présenteront sur la professeure
agrégée de lettres alors oui car venant
des meilleurs lycées de france n est là
pour ça on s'ennuie beaucoup à vous lire
vous savez à paris aux limites encore
les dégâts en banlieue on n'est pas chez
les jeunes profs totalement
inexpérimentés alors pour contraire les
choses a nommé des professeurs
expérimentés agathe kaufmann on a parlé
de votre envie de vous permettez dans un
collège de bons livres qui conseille
avec les élèves c'est toi respecter tout
de suite je m'appelle en soit toute
[Musique]
façon toujours c'est le type allez vous
avoir votre place
oui internet donnez le moi c'est vous
gâchez pas votre chien sur quoi tu
ressentais paix qu'on peut lui arriver
ici là dans le collège on a vu tout de
suite que d'aller droit dans le mur et
maintenant tu es là tu arrives tu me
fais des leçons de morale nous et non
pas les voir passer une heure de col du
border de quatre heures
on ne va pas bien à mon jeu c'est parce
que c'est de pire en pire ce collège
ainsi gain d'un peu plus c'est
impossible de leur cher pour j'arrive
pas fous les mauvaises notes les
humiliations donc ils croient qu'ils
seront pas secondes
les billets sont intégralement disputée
en faire des exercices de grammaire et
fichiers chronos et j'ai envie de
glisser ou sur la tête de ma mère
sais tu travailles demande tu diras bien
le verrons bien
[Musique]
je m'éclate je vous prie de bien vouloir
m'excuser non au mois de mai que nos
papas
[Musique]